hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from the super bad to rapid
in blitz tournament being held in
Bucharest Romania in this they are a
country club it's three days of rapid
event followed by two days of blitz in
the rapid section you have 25 minutes
per player no increment but you get a 10
second delay starting from 1 so this is
a game from round 1 really an impressive
game by both players I'm sure you're
gonna enjoy it so let's just dive
straight into it
Chuck Norris with the white pieces
against Vishwanath on Island let's see
let's see how it goes
our timing with the white pieces opens
with Knight to f3
so the reti opening is on the board we
have d5 and now g3 the Kings Indian
attack
we have c5 by Anand principle reply
grabbing the center while your opponent
is developing pieces on the King side
Bishop to g2 Knight to f6 and castles
and undergoes g6 is preparing to
fianchetto his dark squared Bishop with
d4 seek a person d4 Knight captures and
Bishop to g7 now developing procuring
the castle Knight back to b3 not even
waiting for Knight to c6 which Anand of
course goes for and now Knight to c3
he's he prefers this instead of c4 c4 is
a is a force line but tonight to c3
developing the piece but on the other
hand your piece is now blocking the C do
pawn so sort of a trade-off ecigs by
Anand and now this position has been
reached among the among the other
players by Anand himself in 2017 Anand
had this exact same position against
Hikaru Nakamura in the London chest
classic that game ended in a draw and in
that game Nakamura went for efore but
here artemyev plays a4 and it is a new
move so it is as of move 9 that we have
a completely new game on our hands the
idea is of course a5 a6 he wants to
create weaknesses on the Queen side and
he is flexible with his epon he might
push at the e3 or to e4 in the future so
Anand is now half the you know consider
everything about the new position so he
castles with a 5 by Artemyev as planned
and the rook to e8
we have rook to e1 and now
rook to b8 preparing to meet a sex with
b6 which will be very interesting
artemyev pushes plays Bishop to f4 he
says move the rook away from b8 but
Allen says no way thank you for allowing
me to play e5 with tempo so Bishop to g5
and now d for inviting the knight to go
for a double attack against the f6
Knight so here the the knight is
attacked twice but it's defended twice
so it's not a problem
Bishop to f5 by Island and now we have a
six and here
Anand calculates properly because you
have to be careful if you push b6 the
knight on c6 is no longer defended and
if this knife moves well then you might
lose the piece but Anand calculate
properly he plays B 6 and now artemiev
goes for it it's hard to say how much of
this art enemy have had at home over the
board in his preparation and how much
was over the board but well safe to say
Knight captures on f6 Bishop captures
and now if you capture here then Queen
recaptures and the c6 Knight is defended
so here Artemis played Bishop Tadros on
c6 which of course if you don't want to
be down a piece you have to give up the
exchange so Allen place bunch of
characters on g5 and artemyev wins the
exchange Bishop captures 98 with Queen
captures on EA and now h4 making more
room for the King while also pushing the
best back brush up to h6 and now c3
attacking Allen strong center so here
for the sacrifice exchange Anand has a
very strong center he has the bishop
pair and well if if Artemyev can open up
the position to make use of his rooks
then of course he should be better but
if not then black just has a very strong
center and the bishop pair so rook the
c8 not allowing seek after sandy for
because bishop the c2 just wins the
night for Tim if has to figure out how
to how to open lines for his rooks night
the d2 is played and now efore by Anand
this is a deadly idea again seek a
person before it's it's amazing what you
know poison there is in the position
because if C captures here then III and
you just don't have a good
apply to this I mean if you move if you
play Knight f3 then Bishop the C two
wins the Queen it's just it's just
wonderful stuff you and all of these
squares are taken
you can play Queen c1 but then you run
into e captures and I have to check
which picks up the Queen so e for really
and also move by Anand with knife to f1
again guarding the e3 square but now on
unjust place D captures in C 3 we have B
captures on c3 and now III and now again
you have to well you can't really
capture if you capture and trade it's
not something you want to do and the
white king is just too naked if King h2
Queen f2 if you go something like this
then Bishop to e4 check King moves route
captures on c3 it's just game over for
white on the other hand you could play
f3 although it's it's an ugly move but
it's the best White has and now comes
Bishop g7 here threatening Bishop
captures on c3 you will win back your
exchange doesn't really matter what
white play still you're gonna capture
here you're gonna lose the rook so you
might as well give it up well like this
captures captures arrow and it still
comes with with protecting the pawn here
so now you you retain a better position
and you also grab back your exchange so
after e3 Artemia tries Queen to a for
trying to centralize this Queen and also
offering a queen trade but now on a
place Bishop d7 pushes the Queen back
Queen d4 and now he captures an f2 with
check with Queen captures an f2 and now
rook captures and c3 so grabbing that
pawn now you're still up the exchange
okay you've opened up some lines but
Anand is now also up upon and the ace
exponent is a fairly weak one so you're
not expecting it still live for very
long
rook 8d one buyer timid and now Bishop
to f8 of course preparing Bishop to c5
which would create a lot of problems for
white so Queen to f4 and now Bishop to
b5 going after the a6 pawn also
pressuring the e2 point they're still no
danger of capturing it if natural rock
DT would just trap your bishop so King
to h2 first allowing this cap Trani to
but of course I'm not interested Bishop
captures in 86 is played we have looked
at a1 now after the bishop moves our
Tamia will be able to capture on a7 then
perhaps he could create some threats
against the f7 pawn but Bishop the b7 by
Anand and rook captures on a7 and now
Queen to c6 and here are Tamia finds a
most interesting defense here well our
team a plays my the threat of course is
just a queen to h1 which will be made so
Artemia finds nice the e3 which is a
very interesting move so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find a
winning move for Anand in this position
while I give you a couple of seconds for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations it's really not an easy
move to find and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show
rook captures on e3 doesn't work if you
found this very story this would end up
only in a draw because here White has ok
you've removed the defender of the
g-tube the square but now Rukh a person
b7 will ruin your plans and here you can
either just trade trade which are only
gonna be down a piece or if Queen e6
going after d2 pawn now you go rook F 1
and after rook captures here you're just
gonna block trade and now you are still
still up the exchange ok black is down
to pawns but it's it's very unlikely
that you will be able to put you know
make something more than a draw here for
example if Bishop c5 you defend the b6
pawn now comes route be checking g7 and
our Queen B to allow the perpetual after
King h6 Queen d2 checking here Queen
checks and you will not be able to block
because of Ruby g8 check just to loses
the Queen for black so unfortunately
rook captures on e3 doesn't work sorry
for all of you found that but if you
found Bishop to d6 then you are you have
just defeated Chuck Norris
because now it makes all the difference
because now the rook and Bishop are
honoring that g3 pawn and now the line
works for example our teammates like
Queen to d4 here and then now on a plate
rook captures on d3 and now it's
different
of course you have to prevent mate so
rook captures on b7 is played but now
actress Angie 3 with check that's the
point with kink the g1 and now between
captures and v7 and here if Artemia
grabs
grabs this one then there should capture
sunny one that was the point of the the
whole point
and even after Quinta check King g7
Queen 'if I've check you get f6 and
there are no more checks the Queen
covers the entire seventh rank so it's
not a problem
so after Queen captures on b7 our team
have tried Queen to d8 check but
honestly King to g7 we have Queen to b4
check and after.look to e5 it was in
this position that Vladislav artemiev
resigned the game as there is nothing
more he can do he's just down a piece
for example if you try something like
Queen c3 to pick up the bishop here
black just picks up the rock it doesn't
matter this comes with check because
after f6 we get the exact the exact same
position where there are no more checks
into position and you're just down a
piece and if you try to create some
chances without going for the bishop
let's say Ruby 1 you go after the pawn
here still just f6 it's not a problem
you allow this capture and now you run
into Bishop 2h to check so if you
capture it rook captures fall by Queen
to g2 mate if you don't capture it then
you just get Quint h1 and you are again
getting made it so not not much you can
do here III you can't allow the ship to
g1 also a very nice idea so let's say
III Bishop do you want check kinky to
rook captures here can cast go Queens
you to check King move to d1 and now you
just continue checking the King Queen f3
check Kings are gonna go back to C - now
you can do rook e to check King to c1
Queen to f1 check and now after you
block with the Queen just check moves
and ok we've played it out just so you
can see that there is no even a possible
way for our team if to continue this so
after Luke e5 a great game by Anand
by artemyev as well he prepared really
nicely he grabbed the exchange in the
beginning but that's how powerful the
bishop pair from hell can be and
especially when you have a nice Center
and Allan found those very nice pawn
pushes which never allowed Artemis to
bring his rooks into the game so really
impressive game 2 points for Anand the
forgot to mention you get two points for
a win in rapid only one
point for a win in the Blitz game and
the blitz blitz action will be a double
round-robin so in case you were
wondering sir that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Victor of ice berry McMurdo Galina
kotsaba at Irish car park and Daniel G
clapper the third I imagine for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos your
thing called for watching and I will see
soon
continuing the short coverage of the
feeder Grand Prix and this super but
rapid abuts tournament I don't know how
much I will be able to cover as I'm
going to Germany tomorrow at about
Piermont but like I said I might visit
Hamburg I might with the defeated Grand
Prix venue so if any will be there I
will also announcer we can grab a beer
or something so thank you all I will see
soon and him an excellent rest of your
day